I realize the two-level model may seem
like a bit of a cartoon compared to
real memory hierarchies that you
know from either other courses or
maybe even real life.
So why bother?
Well, the two-level model really
does capture the most important
performance effects of real memories,
namely capacity and transfer size.
Now, there's been a lot of research on
locality-sensitive algorithms based on
this model.
So, it's helpful to know it in order to
come up with sensible ways to extend it.
To exploit a memory hierarchy
algorithmically, what can you do?
The main technique you thought about
in this lesson is to organize your data
access to increase data use.
The other important pair of concepts
in this lesson were those of
computational intensity and
machine balance.
Here's a general rule of thumb
based on those two concepts.
If you want your algorithm to scale
well to future memory hierarchies,
then you want the intensity of your
algorithm to at least match, but
preferably exceed the balance
point of the machine.
You'll take this idea much further
in some of the other lessons.